Hello, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I will speak about a question that is quite frequently discussed on our forum at LingQ.
That is, "Do children learn languages better than adults do?" For those of you that don't know about LingQ, it's a website for language learning and you can learn up to 21 languages, you can register for free. To get the most out of it, it's better to become a paying member. This has many advantages, it's 10 dollars a month.
Anyway.
Normally it is said, I believe, that children learn better.
Although recently I read a piece of work by the Centre for Applied Linguistics in the USA who claim the contrary.
And if when reading the study it was clear that the work and research that supported the study was based on what happens in the classroom, in formal teaching. And it is possible and I'd even agree that in a situation of formal learning, in a class, and when one tries to learn a language deliberately, it is possible that adults are just as talented, just as capable, or even more so than children.
But it's not necessarily in the classroom where languages are learnt. This evening I will be at an event, where we're going to listen to Mr Matvei Ganapolski of Echo Moskvi, a Moscow radio station that I've been listening to for 6 years. It''s been a part of my Russian language learning and I'll have the opportunity to meet him, well, I'm very happy.
Plus there'll be around 200 Russian immigrants, and I already know that most of them won't speak English very well, especially the older ones. The younger immigrants, those around 30, 20, 40 years old will speak it better. Then their children will speak without an accent, or maybe completely without an accent. Like natives.
We have some friends, for example a couple from China, the parents who have been living in Vancouver for 6 years speak English very poorly, almost not at all, they understand a little. They go to the language immersion school, well not immersion but an English language school, subsidised by the state, and they go in their Porsche as they're very rich. They make no progress at all, whereas their 14 year old child, so 8 when he came, speaks English like a native.
However, my own little children go to a French immersion school here in Vancouver. So all the pupils are English speakers whose Chemistry, History or whatever lessons are taught in French. Well after 9, 10, 11 years, they don't speak French very well. They understand, but they don't speak very well. And I believe that a motivated adult who'd go to an immersion school for 10 years would speak better.
So what are the conclusions? OK. I believe that statistically, well if we consider immigrants it's evident that in the majority of cases, if not all the cases, the children speak better, whether it's English, French in France, German in Germany, any language of a country that hosts immigrants.
Why then?
Because the child does not learn the language deliberately!
The child wants to be a part of a group, he wants to become like his friends, like others ... this desire to participate, to communicate, to imitate, without getting worked up about it. Maybe a few children feel hung up with it, but not as much as adults.
In principle I don't think children criticise the newcomer from who-knows-where who speaks with an accent because he will quickly blend in and speak like the rest.
And especially I think a child is less inclined to doubt himself, whereas an adult has both less of a desire to be part of this group, because these are the Chinese, the French, they come with their own cultural baggage, I'd even say a sort of cultural ego, they won't let that go to become even temporarily Canadian English, whatever it is.
So there is this resistance, and yet the adult who sees himself as intelligent in his own language doesn't want to look at all stupid, so he has a lot of insecurity, inhibition, etc., that in principle children don't have.
Children learn better because they want to ... they are not students of the language, they are quite simply little beings that want to participate in another society, another culture with other ways, and they want to imitate all that makes up this other society.
But if this means learning as if it's homework, well, I think yes, adults can learn.
But I think what's interesting is that in most cases adults don't learn well, what could we do to encourage them to learn better?
In my opinion, if we take myself as an example, I enjoy learning languages, and today I can talk, depending on my proficiency, up to 12 languages. But the first language, it wasn't a foreign language because in Canada French is an official language.
Anyway the first language that I had to study was French. When I was at school I didn't learn like... well I could recite the verbs that used être or avoir, etc, but I couldn't speak. But when I was 16 I began to get interested in the language, I wanted to get to know people, the French speakers in Quebec, because I should say in the 50s Montreal was effectively two cities. The Anglophone city and the Francophone city.
So we had very little contact with the French speakers. And when I was 16 and I said to myself, hey, this is interesting, the culture, the civilisation, films, music, theatre, etc. So when I wanted to communicate and participate and become like them, well then I was able to learn very quickly. And I believe that's what's important.
The advantage for children is that they're not there to deliberately learn the verbs, the rules etc., they simply want to participate and to communicate. The more that we can copy this attitude children have - in other words worrying less about little errors and that, and only wanting to participate, communicate, become like them - the better we can learn. And becoming like them doesn't mean that we leave our own culture forever, that we abandon our culture.
I speak 12 languages and I remain who I am, Canadian English, most of my friends come from the same background.
Every time I learn a language, Chinese, Japanese or whatever, I try to become them! I want to be Chinese, Japanese, French, Russian and so on. And that's important, that's what children do.
And I believe that if adults can copy this way of learning languages, they will learn better.
For example in my case, when I begin to learn a language, I will particularly listen and read a lot.
About the country, the language, the history, the culture, etc, so that it gets into my brain.
And also because I want to learn words, and I want to improve my ability to understand, understanding is fundamental. After that, when I want to start speaking more, well, to speak well one must speak a lot, that's obvious.
But I don't worry so much about little details of the grammar at the beginning. To listen and to read I don't require a great notion of the grammar. But later on when I want to speak better, then I will certainly look at the grammar rules once again, I would already have skimmed over them but without being able to remember, I'll look at that.
The second, third or fourth time that I look at the grammar rules I will already have a reference point, because I've listened to the language a lot.
And even after having read things that are quite difficult, I might go and read something easy where I know all the words, but specifically to be able to concentrate on certain structures, certain grammar points that have been causing me some difficulty.
But in order for me to really get into the language and the culture, I don't worry about my mistakes, I communicate, I talk, I listen, I read, I want to participate in this culture.
And I believe that that's a bit, if you like it's a bit like how a child proceeds.
A child doesn't want to learn the grammar rules, he wants to understand, he wants to communicate, voila.
So to conclude, in principle from what I can see, children learns better.
But I think there are aspects of the child's way of learning that us adults can imitate.
So that's what I'd suggest and moreover it's the principle learning method that we use at LingQ.
That's all, thank you and I hope that if you have opposing opinions, comments, questions, let me know.
Goodbye and thank you.